[Music]
on march 15
2011 martin sims was wandering down the
streets of carson california
his clothes were ragged he was filthy
and jibbering like a madman with a full
beard and long unkempt hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition
what made martin's sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing
for three years when he was interviewed
by police they asked him where he'd been
all this time
they couldn't believe his answer he'd
been trapped in an ikea since
2008 but this was no ordinary ikea
this was a dangerous anomaly that would
come to be known as
scp-3008 martin's strange answers in his
interview were laughed off by his
interviewing officers who assumed he was
either crazy or under the influence of
something
but they caught the attention of an scp
foundation field agent embedded in the
precinct
the report was passed up the chain to a
local site director who approved a
detachment of foundation field
operatives
to look into martin's case while he was
reluctant to lead the foundation agents
back to the offending ikea the
foundation can be extremely persuasive
his screams of please i'm begging you
don't take me back don't make me go back
were noted but ultimately disregarded
when the scp foundation had triangulated
the position of scp-3008
which was indeed an active ikea the
entire retail zone was closed and
barricaded
under the pretense of a severe black
mold infestation
armed foundation personnel also arrived
on the site shortly after
based on martin's vague statements that
there were creatures of some kind inside
due to his deteriorating mental health
martin was unable to provide a great
deal
of lucid information on the specific
traits of scp-3008
but one phrase he kept repeating was
bigger on the inside
once researchers were satisfied that
martin had delivered all the pertinent
information he was able to he was
administered foundation amnesty to erase
his memory of the last three years
and return to his family a cover story
was formulated martin had been kidnapped
and abused for three years by a mentally
unbalanced stalker in downtown carson
he'd been able to escape as said stalker
took his own life out of guilt a suicide
that the foundation expertly fabricated
to make their cover story air tight with
the loose end of martin sims taken care
of the true observation of scp-3008
could begin
a base set around the perimeter of the
mysterious ikea kept a 24-hour watch on
the building
covering all potential entrances and
exits no exploratory missions had yet
been approved by the foundation ethics
committee so they first wanted to
perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store's anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building after a week of nothing
it appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class d
personnel to explore the interior of
scp-3008
the d-class operatives would be split
into four squads of five men
alpha bravo charlie and delta squad each
would be assigned a different quadrant
of the store
and would deliver information back to
the control team on site via a live
audio and video link
three of the four teams upon entering
the store reported nothing out of the
ordinary
neither the audio or video they were
sending back indicated anything
different from a standard ikea store
from the flat pack wardrobes to the
swedish meatballs team delta however
suddenly began experiencing a scrambled
audio and video connection
shortly after communication with team
delta dropped off entirely
they disappeared somewhere inside the
store and haven't been
seen since with one notable exception
after the disappearance and the
extraction of teams foundation
researchers classified scp-3008
as euclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store
and even then seemingly not the entire
interior
the anomalous area within scp-3008
became known as scp-3008-1
and containment appeared to be 100
secure there was no telling how many
people had already gone missing in the
store over the years but the
disappearances must be stopped
the foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of
scp-3008
but it appeared they could prevent any
further incidents by simply preventing
other civilians
from accessing the ikea store martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium
until a surviving member of delta teams
suddenly reappeared
the date was november 3rd 2011 it was a
cold night
a few hours after what would have been
closing time if the store were still
active and seven months after the
extraction teams had disappeared
somewhere in the confines of scp-3008
there had been
no anomalous activity outside the store
since the perimeter was first secured
and the foundation researchers hadn't
expected that to change
until the last surviving member of delta
team came barging out of the store's
entrance
startled field operatives were amazed to
see him again but they were even more
amazed to see what was following him
out of the store repeating the same
phrase the store is now closed please
exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the delta team survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an ikea
store employee
the being definitely was not human it
was around
seven feet tall with no visible face the
entity had grossly extended limbs
with each arm being around five or six
feet long and ending in a huge
oversized hand the whole process was so
sudden
that the field agents present at the
perimeter weren't able to save the death
team survivor
as the entity reached forward with his
freakishly long arms
grabbed him and twisted his head off
like a child with a doll
the field operative's present drew their
weapons and peppered the entity with
bullets it would later be classified as
scp-3008-2
the being appeared to collapse and die
from the physical trauma
at which point it and the body of the
former delta team survivor were taken
for an autopsy by foundation researchers
there were no biological abnormalities
of the body of the delta team survivor
so it did not appear that the anomalous
properties
of scp-3008-1 had any effect on the
physiology of its occupants
he was not malnourished despite being
missing for months and the contents of
his stomach look to be half digested
food consistent with the menu
of a typical ikea store restaurant
scp-3008-2 on the other hand
raised a number of perplexing biological
questions the autopsy revealed that the
creature's clothes were actually part of
its body
like an additional layer of skin the
creature lacked blood or any kind of
vascular system
even stranger the entity didn't appear
to have bones or internal organs
not even a brain or nervous system it
was a being made entirely of skin all
the way to its core
how it was able to move or even live for
that matter remains a mystery
though when you work for the scp
foundation you learn to accept that some
things will always remain
unexplained one thing was certain though
martin sims was right about his monsters
after the incident with delta team the
foundation deemed that sending manned
explorations into the heart of scp-3008
was too much of a liability
and planned a series of drone-based
reconnaissance missions into the anomaly
the first of these drones experienced
connection issues and failed when
attempting to venture into the ikea's
anomalous zone
however after a lengthy period of trial
and error the foundation was able to
establish a more secure connection with
its drones
even went deep into the scp-3008-1
anomalous zone it was only then that
some of the most extraordinary
discoveries were made
scp-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of
spatial reality
as the area of the ikea's interior was
at least an order of magnitude larger
than its exterior just as martin seems
it said
it was bigger on the inside but just how
much bigger the foundation has yet to
find evidence of any physical
terminators within the store that might
indicate scp-3008-1 has an end point
while an area of at least 10 kilometers
squared has been uncovered in scp-3008-1
it could in theory be infinite laser
rangefinder tests which are normally
very reliable
have only given inconclusive results
interestingly the anomalous area doesn't
have any clear
visual differences from the rest of the
ikea store except that it extends
forever
an individual trapped within the
confines of scp-3008-1
wouldn't even realize they've entered an
anomalous zone until they tried to
locate an exit and leave
at which point they'd find they were
already hopelessly lost
the geography of scp-3008-1 does at
least appear to be consistent
so people trapped within are
theoretically able to retrace their
steps
and escape if they haven't already
ventured too deep according to data
collected during the drone
reconnaissance
missions scp-3008-2 of which there
appear to be a vast population
would wander the stores aimlessly during
the day they are unresponsive to the
drones presence and did not appear to be
aggressive
while the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
follow the same
overall trend clothes consistent with an
ikea uniform
no face either seemingly too tall or too
short and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies
as the foundation began sending drones
deeper into scp-3008-1 they found
another incredible discovery there was
an unknown population of humans trapped
inside
ikea's anomalous zone and these people
had used the ikea furniture around them
to create entire settlements
and towns within the store there were
several of these towns all of which
seemed to cohabitate peacefully
even foundation personnel found this
development in their research to be
truly extraordinary
since scp-3008 was first identified
there have been only 14
civilian escapes some had been trapped
inside for months
others had been in there for years some
far longer than martin's three-year
stint
while every one of these escapees has
eventually been released back to their
home
after a liberal application of amnestics
and a proper cover story has been
devised
the foundation interviewed each of them
extensively first according to each of
these escapees the people trapped inside
the ikea have built an entirely new
society
across the various settlements contrary
to the lord of the flies expectations of
a group of people isolated and afraid
there is immense cooperation between the
trapped civilians the food in the
several ikea restaurants in scp-3008-1
mysteriously replenishes while nobody's
there so there's no threat of starving
and the automatic turning on and off of
the lights forms as a rudimentary kind
of day and night cycle
night time however is when things get
dangerous as the scp-3008-2 entities
which are known to the people inside as
the staff become
extremely hostile after dark aggressive
hordes of the staff swarmed the
settlements at night
repeating this door is now closed please
exit the building the civilians inside
are usually able to repel these attacks
with minimal casualties
but the constant war of attrition slowly
wears down those inside
the bodies of the creatures also need to
be removed from the area after each
attack
as the presence of corpses or even parts
of corpses has been known to heighten
the ferocity of the next night's attack
during the day the staff return to a
docile and unresponsive state
though they'll still defend themselves
violently if anyone dares to attack
over the course of the interviews with
the 14 escapees foundation researchers
were able to answer another of their key
questions
how had so many people gone missing in
the store for so long without being
noticed
but the answer they received only raised
many more unsettling queries
according to the escapees there were
people inside the settlements that
despite being otherwise of entirely
sound mind and standard intelligence
seem to lack very common knowledge that
even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the international space station
orbiting the earth or stranger still the
existence of the statue of liberty
this led the researchers to a
frightening conclusion scp-3008-1 may
not only be a nexus point of multiple
ikea stores in our dimension
it could be connected to ikeas in every
dimension where ikeas exist
while it only abducts a handful of
people from each store over an extended
period of time
it suddenly becomes clear how this scp
was able to trap so many people without
detection over such a long period of
time
which in turn led to an even more
terrifying revelation
the scp foundation may not have
scp-3008-1
as contained as they thought it might
even be tucked away in an ikea store
somewhere near you
just waiting for you to visit after all
there's always room for one more